being moderate is a green flag you see
this new one about extremist views
William shared the graph of it I haven't
seen this one but uh let me get your
take on this this is awesome researchers
pulled over a thousand registered us
voters aged 18 to 34 a majority of both
men and women consider far rightism and
Far leftism to be red flags in a
potential partner 76% of women and 59%
of men consider identifying as a Maga
Republican to be a turn off M 64% of men
and 55% of women said they'd also swipe
left on someone identifying as a
communist so that was high number of
women 76% for Maga 64% of men for
communist 55% of women said that
listening to Joe Rogan was a red
flag about modern wisdom 35 that wasn't
on the 35% of men uh 41% of men said the
same for a woman being into
astrology okay 20% % of women uh 33% of
men said red flag for they say black
lives matter 14% of women 53% of women
for they refuse to see the Barbie
movie uh 53% of women uh 58% of women
for they say there are only two genders
so more women concerned about the two
genders thing than the Barbie movie
interesting uh what that is but yet just
overall it seems like um far rightism
far leftism
uh being moderate is a green flag
basically like having but that being
said how is saying that there are only
two genders like an extreme position how
like I would have thought that that
would have been the moderate position
right like I guess it depends yeah but
the the Bol has being turned upside down
but yet overall when it comes to dating
it seems like a majority of both men and
women consider far rightism and Far
leftism to be red flags in a potential
partner what what what age group was
this are these young young 18 to 18 to
okay yeah that makes a lot yeah that
makes sense I mean yeah I mean you
you've probably seen some of these data
too about sort of the political
Divergence of young men and young women
um which is really I mean it's really
interesting because uh a lot of the the
Press media will concentrate on you know
the supposed uh right-wing
radicalization of young men when
actually most of the sort of political
psychology survey data indicates the
reverse where men are young men are
slightly turning to the right there sort
of a a slight turn whereas for young
women there's a sharp like a sharp rise
in young women identifying as left or
far left so it's actually the the women
uh who are being sort of uh uh
radicalized or or turning to a more
extreme Direction um yeah but we don't
mind about that one we know we don't
need to care about that yeah well I mean
well so I think like in in terms of like
violence and so forth right there's no
there's no young female
syndrome or or if there is one it would
be it would manifest itself differently
the female L house the F the long house
yeah um but yeah I mean in terms of the
sort of the classic threats of terrorism
and so forth I mean but but uh yeah
that's that's interesting I mean so so
some of those like yeah the the two
genders one that's
interesting 58% of women I found like
the yeah there's there's a sort of a a
neat reversal there of like Maga
Republicans versus Communists where most
men seemingly okay with dating a a Maga
identifying woman but women uh are more
okay with dating a communist identifying
man here's the thing right that it's not
apples for apples right like uh 35% of
men said that a woman listening to Joe
Rogan was a red flag but a man listening
to Joe Rogan and a woman listening to
Joe Rogan is not the same thing that's
true too yeah you know what I mean yeah
like there was one about uh owning a gun
that like some quite high percentage of
women said that owning a gun was a red
flag right in America um but a woman
owning a gun is not the same as a man
owning a gun right and and the same for
listening to Joe Rogan and so on and so
forth so I it's it makes for very
interesting reading but I actually think
that like if a woman does listen to Joe
ran there'll be some non-zero number of
men in that like that's a like that's a
boy show like why why like oh maybe
she's super disagreeable or maybe she's
like going to try and arm wrestle me in
bed or something like yeah yeah yeah
yeah I have I've heard this um you know
just just speaking with young guys that
uh you know they are to some extent sort
of bothered by these gender differences
in politics and how more and more young
women are sort of identifying in in a
more sort of sharp leftwing Direction um
but then they also sort of lament that
you know a lot of young because you have
to be you know to some degree
psychologically peculiar if you're a
young woman who is a sort of right-wing
person or or or identifying openly as a
conservative because you're sort of
going against the grain right like you
are an outlier in that sense and that of
often sort of coincides with other
things that young men are kind of
annoyed by and so it's like it's the
astrology
41% of men said that a woman being into
astrology that one was confusing to me I
think like that's fine you know that's
like a very to me like a feminine way of
thinking you know like I think it's you
know I can't remember who what who was
it that said was it they said uh um uh
the big five is astrology for men I've
heard that for evolutionary psychology
evolutionary psychology evary psychology
is astrology for men yeah but I mean
well that's fine but then like you know
a lot of well a lot of men but but at
least in my experience more women are
interested in the mbti the Myers Briggs
and that is I mean it's you know it's
not it's not completely astrology but
it's more like astrology than the big
five I yeah it is I had uh uh Spencer
Greenberg on the show do you know
Spencer real interesting dude I think
I've seen some of his I got intro to him
from William mascal um just super
interesting guy mathematician but just
does science like I don't know what he's
funded by maybe himself but uh and he
did a a huge breakdown of like
predictive power of uh Myers Briggs
versus Big Five versus other stuff
versus other stuff and uh my braks is
like I think it's like 18% accurate
basically on actual predisposition of
things but uh yeah it is that that's
astrology for astrology I think uh what
was that study about higher female
status and gender equality being
associated with lower female uh relative
to male happiness and relationship
satisfaction and stuff like that yeah
this was a study I came across I think
it was published in
2015 uh which yeah essentially found
that that higher levels of wealth and
and sociopolitical equality among the
genders is associated with lower levels
of of relative happiness for women
compared to men and the researchers
speculate this may have something to do
with increasing levels of employment uh
the the pressure to obtain higher levels
of Education uh among women in
particular and that this is actually
sort of uh uh uh dampening women's
levels of happiness and to me this this
connects with another uh and this one is
you know this this classic finding of
the the Paradox of declining female
happiness which is essentially that
since the 1970s uh women's happiness
relative to to men's has declined so to
be clear everyone's so so relative to
the 1970s um everyone is less happy
today compared to the 1970s but in the
1970s men were actually happier uh no no
no sorry women were happier than men so
women had higher rates of Happiness
relative to men in the 1970s and people
generally were happier overall fast
forward to the present and
uh things have reversed men are now
happier than women although overall
people report being less happy um and so
yeah that that study that I pointed out
that was an interesting one to me
because yeah I mean the the message that
a lot of young people receive today is
what are the keys to happiness you know
you you you work hard you go you get a
you go to college you get a degree you
get a high-paying job you sort of Follow
that cookie cutter track and what is the
the purpose of all of this um and and
it's you know I I I suppose you most
people say well they want to be happy
and so you go through the education and
employment route maybe you go to law
school after college you sort of get the
credentials you go through the whatever
the fellowships and all these different
programs and at the end of the tunnel
you're hoping that you'll be happy uh
and actually uh for both men and women
doesn't seem to be working but for women
in particular um because they've had the
sharpest decline right because remember
they were happier and now they're you
know so they're exactly and and so their
uh uh diminishing happiness has actually
been sort of more pronounced relative to
men um
the men H the men's happiness being sort
of higher than women's is interesting as
well and I wonder if that is almost sort
of uh the the reversal in some ways of
course they're less happy overall but
why would they be happier than women and
I wonder if that's to some degree
because they don't feel as much pressure
anymore the sort of um you know back in
the day men were sort of pressured more
to be earners and providers and so on
and there was a sort of a economic
pressure associated with that and now
that you don't really have to work I
mean seeing young men are sort of
dropping out of college they're dropping
out of higher education and employment
and at least in the short term depending
on how the survey questions are
presented if it's just you know how do
you feel generally or how do you feel
today or what have you I think a lot of
you guys might be like yeah I don't I
don't I didn't have to go to class given
the fact that men were previously less
happy and relative to then are now less
happy also it's just that really the the
change the big change here is the women
right that's FL I wonder whether um like
the male dissatisfaction with the uh
gameful employment state of seeking
providing thing was just baked in
already it's like oh okay like we we we
already knew this like Granddad was spit
and sord dust and he was unhappy and dad
was spit and sord dust and he was
unhappy and I'm spit and sord dust and
I'm unhappy but there is a little bit
less pressure to do this uh was that
Candice Blake that did that one uh the
the the female happiness study I don't
recall the the the authors of that one
but it was in the Journal of Happiness
studies she definitely taught me about
either that or something similar which
is yeah that you know the gender pay Gap
positively predicts relationship
satisfaction oh I have seen that yeah
yeah I think yeah I read that paper um
which is you know
it's and it's it's funny because so it
predicts relationship satisfaction if
men earn more than women and then it
also there was there was a reversal of
this um I don't know if if if cace was a
study on this were different different
uh authors but they found that when when
women in marriages earn more than men
that this predicts higher rates of of of
arguments of verbal aggression on behalf
of the woman of just general
relationship High higher rates of
domestic violence infidelity on the part
of the man as well men are more likely
to cheat when they earn less uh 50%
increase in the use of erectile
dysfunction medication when a woman's
the primary bread winner I've heard that
too yeah that's uh yeah that's pretty
it's pretty I mean it's Grim but then
you know I I uh you know here's an
anecdote I remember when I was in
undergrad and I had this conversation it
was uh you know it was me and like this
this group of of women these female
students and one of them you know she
was a pretty hardcore feminist and she
said that it should be 50/50 like 50% of
women uh should be working you know 50%
of women like if it's the case that 50%
of women are working 50% of women should
be at home and same for men you know if
50% of men should be working 50% of men
at home and uh and then you know so then
I was basically just sitting back like I
was not going to get entangled this but
then some of the other women were saying
you know okay so you know but like would
you actually be like okay with that like
your husband staying at home I don't
really know whatever and then and then
finally I decided to to jump in and I
said like you know speaking to to this
this this young feminist woman I said
yeah can like so I know that you plan on
going to law school you're very smart
you're going to be very successful like
how would you feel like your husband is
at home I don't know changing diapers
and taking care of the kids and you're
at you know you're at a a prestigious
law firm with a bunch of high-powered
attorneys like how would that you know
you think you'd be happy in that
situation and her response was um wow I
I got like I think I just felt A tingle
when you said High powerered attorneys
like I got really excited when you said
that that was basically her reaction wow
and it was half joking but half serious
and all of the women laughed I laughed
too it it was you know it was a good
response but like I think you know that
there was an element of seriousness
there right that like when you you know
when she's sort of fantasizing about
like yeah rubbing shoulders with all of
these you know high-powered successful
at the top of their game and then you
got your husband at home and I think
it's just it's different right like it's
men and women are different we're
attracted to different things thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that clip with Rob you will love my
fulllength podcast with him which you
can watch right here go on tap it tap it